[Music]
so I think first thing that will be
useful for the audience I think would be
kind of a quick round of introductions
so they understand and know what your
roles are so mark if you could start
start with you your your role and what
do you do at your company my name is
Mark I'm involved with information
security at la block companies limited
we're a company based out of Canada
we're involved with one of the larger
the leaders for pharmacy and retail in
Canada we've about 200,000 employees
across Canada both full-time and
part-time my role specifically around
assessing security solutions that are
going to be used in our different
platforms and how we address our very
specific threat landscape sure
hello my name is shahara I'm CIO for
exhibit Exuma means making a
next-generation seam making a you know
our advanced analytics technology
available for you know companies to make
to get more out of the regime and I've
been with xmin for about a year as CIO
previously I've been with Imperva you
know heading both infrastructure in C so
for Imperva and it exhibits you know
kind of cio leading the IT and the
InfoSec operations as well as in charge
of building a cloud product in our cloud
seam offering which we recently
announced at RSA and hi guys my name is
Jason Lau I'm the vice president of
information security for core logic core
logic is another one of those companies
that you don't know but you really touch
all the time if you guys have done a
mortgage loan you've probably on the
backend that probably involved core
logic anywhere from 10 to 20 different
times from the credit check process to
the home appraiser to the mortgage risk
data that we provide to the mortgage
lending companies so my job is to
protect data we've been moving we've
been very aggressive in moving all of
our applications sensitive data or
otherwise to Google cloud so my focus is
really cloud security and cloud
automation
my name is Derrick tomorrow I work for
eBay and most you probably know what he
is we are not just a large marketplace
but we also have many other brands that
sit under eBay so we have StubHub and a
bunch of other classifieds groups that
help users around the world find
services goods and services in their
local communities so my main
responsibility is kind of helping to
plan and research and develop what our
next-gen services platform looks like so
whether it is an extension of a hybrid
cloud environment where we may have data
that exists in a public cloud
environment or or how we further you
know enhance our existing security
program to protect against next-gen
threats my name is John Jenga and I work
for the home depot I stopped a security
engineer and my role at the company is
focused on looking for tools that
provide us with risk assessment our
enhances our ability to do research
assessment across the enterprise both in
the cloud space and on-premise and with
everything shifting to you know cloud
workloads you know we are looking at
different tools we look at different
tools validate that they can provide the
same visibility that we require so that
we can provide our leadership with the
required our risk assessment profiling
for all of the workloads whether they in
the cloud or they are on their own
premise space perfect thank you John
I think one thing that will be useful
for the audience would be to understand
you know what kind of workloads you are
running on GCP and you know how you use
GCP so so John if you start from your
side other ways at this time
anything that you can share and that
people can relate to in the audience so
we have different work levels that
actually run obviously we have different
business processes some that are
customer-facing workloads some that are
you know used internally we run a hybrid
cloud on-premise environment it's a
large environment so we have different
tool sets we have different requirements
and sometimes with you know what the
cloud provides with auto scaling it's
you know very obvious that we also have
to from security perspective be able to
assess what's happening within those
environments in the same way we do it on
their own premise perfect I can't really
talk about a lot of what we run in and
cool cloud and probably a lot of people
in the audience can relate to that but
what we are doing is what my
responsibility is planning for how some
of our brands are planning you know what
that looks like so a lot of it has been
how do we replicate what we currently
have on-premise within a cloud
environment so you know our approach has
been you know taking it from the host or
the application you know to egress or if
not in the reverse so part of what I'm
actually talking about tomorrow is in
further detail is our our test use case
of how we were able to test Google's you
know perimeter defense mechanisms with
cloud armor in integrated with a partner
solution called relays and that was like
pretty much our use case for how we were
able to to protect you know our
potentially protect our workloads in
Google cloud support Logica were
relatively new to Google cloud we
started about a year ago we were now at
about maybe 750 projects and about 7,000
servers I think altogether it's been
it's been really interesting because I
think one of the things we see from from
the security side is that our the amount
of real estate that we have to protect
is really expanding really fast we've
got the on-prem datacenters we've got
data centers from mergers and
acquisitions we had an existing
footprint of AWS we're moving those into
GCP so there's a lot of things in motion
and so there's a lot of things we kind
of have to keep our eyes on especially
from the M&A side will acquire anywhere
from two to three companies a year
and I think now it's more common to
acquire companies that actually have
their own cloud presence so it's right
for us it's really about how can we
unify and centralize them and how
quickly can we get them out of their
cloud environment into our kind of
managed GCP environment okay and and and
Jason just to kind of add on your G
sweetie I think you have a unique kind
of use case on leveraging pieces of G
suite so if you could share some
thoughts around G suite as well how do
you use it yeah certainly so I think you
know we we like most companies start out
with with the office 365 as we moved
closer to G to G see gcp
we found that we were just kind of
getting better value out of the G suite
product line but that came with its own
challenges right I think that when we
looked at traditional content filtering
that kind of gave us this very binary
approach to you can allow traffic or you
can block traffic and we needed to bring
in partners and solutions like like
netskope Caspi to kind of really open up
those connections to say well you know
we want to do more finesse things like
maybe we want to have our users access
our G suite instance but not let them
access their personal cheese suite
instance or we want to kind of pop open
the session and really see what people
are putting into s3 buckets and so
without kind of more modern solutions
like like netskope we we really didn't
have that the ability to address things
from that granularity so today we're not
only thinking about what they're
accessing but we're also thinking about
the activities that they're doing and it
gives us the ability to kind of have
more finessed rules like allow people to
download from different environments but
we're more focused about preventing what
they upload to non-sanctioned
environments perfect thank you and char
you have a unique kind of role in
position of a security company running a
service on GCP where your reputation and
protecting that service is critical to
the business so in that role you know
you know share a little bit about you
know what you're running on GCP and what
was the key challenges that you've seen
yeah absolutely so when we came to
design in our SAS offering and we were
looking at kind of what's most important
to us and and obviously security a lot
of companies say that security is a top
priority but it's really not and and you
know I kind of you know feel that you
know we really try to do it
it exactly put it at the top of mine
because this is what we do like where as
a security software company and if if
our customers cannot trust us and you
know we would not have business and so
that's why we put it as a top priority
and and as we design the product and
keep on making progress this is
something that we always take care of
and and even if it's sometimes slowed us
down and I think that you know most
people here would recognize that
sometimes it's you have to slow down to
get this done right this is what we're
trying to do and we feel that you know
the Google clouds provide us with with a
good platform to do that and and maybe
one more comment about you know partners
offerings I I kind of feel that three
years ago this wasn't the case right you
you would sit in such a session and and
there are maybe a few names are on you
know on the slideshow and not all of
them you know have you know good
solutions and that has change I think
that you know for those of you who are
considering a move now you know the
tools are there you know kind of connect
with your vendors and and you know ask
them what's available and you might be
surprised that most of them do have now
tools that will work in these
environments perfect not really sure I
can follow that out but so I somewhat
like Derek can't speak to specifically
what we have in in GCP but I can't say
Loblaws we're a hybrid and poly call
environment we have a couple different
clouds and we're using a hybrid of
on-premise and cloud infrastructure
we're looking to migrate many of our
on-prem apps or legacy apps to the cloud
we're also looking for for cloud for
some of our web facing applications that
we used for customer facing as well as
some of our data analytics platforms
perfect and Mark starting with you for
the next round when you have we're
designing the security architecture for
Google cloud you know how did you think
about partner solutions what roles they
would play any any partners you want to
mention that played a key role and for
the benefit of the audience you know
what function did they perform and when
folks are thinking about building a
security architecture which are the
different pieces they should be thinking
about yeah for sure so going back to
your first slide that some of you may
have seen it was
you have to take a couple of steps back
google has a responsibility for the
cloud but that isn't to be you shouldn't
confuse that with they're responsible
for everything and some people have
looked at cloud as a mechanism to defer
all of the risk or all of your security
problems to to Google and then you don't
have to worry about anything the
customers responsible for security for
what you put in the cloud so your
workloads your data your your source
codes you have to make sure that you
implement solutions or architecture
solution to address that that starts
with building your threat model and
understanding what specific threats are
actually can potentially exist with with
that migration so some of the the steps
are some of the things that we've looked
at is is network traffic and looking at
a next-generation firewall for for
insight into what traffic is actually
happening and what's going on on your on
your cloud project is it's very
important also with many companies being
fairly immature and understanding how
the clouds can figure out what you can
potentially do looking at solutions that
that monitor the configuration and all
the different switches that you can
potentially configure or is very
important as well and then finally with
many organizations looking to move to
containerized applications and moving
off of traditional infrastructure you
want to make sure that your those
containers are actually being secured
and then you're doing everything that
you can and leveraging the learnings of
some of your partners to make sure that
you're doing the right thing for
security for those migrations perfect
thank you and char from from your
perspective and feel free to share you
know as much detail you feel comfortable
sharing you know from a security company
perspective you've seen all the products
you know all the players when you had to
design your security you know what were
the different components and pieces you
were thinking about how did partner
products help you provide that
comprehensive answer yeah so mark you
talked about a few but I wanted you know
take a slide with different angle I
think that when you start it that's when
you when you're new to cloud environment
you know look at you know what is your
hygiene what's your height the IT
hygiene what's your environment hygiene
where you store your stuff because you
can buy all these products but if there
is you know password so txt on your
desktop there's no product in the world
is going to help you overcome that
so I think that one of our first
priority was to have our environment
clean and hygiene and everything you
know get automated you know through you
know we use some part of products like
Hashi corporate good product for cloud
as well as we use a cloud Waffen DDoS
mitigation service and because these are
things we felt that you know we would be
able to leverage a partner but I you
know for those who are just starting
their journey you know kind of acting a
number one priority should be you know
get your environment clean and then use
the part of products to cover other
aspects that you know that that hygiene
doesn't solve perfect Jason so I think
there's really kind of two components
when we think about partner products
there's the product but then there's the
partner side of it as well and I feel
like yes they have good solutions but I
think that there's a lot to be leveraged
from working with good partners as well
I would I think five years ago I was I
was more the security guy that would go
work with a partner and say here's a
blueprint build this exact thing for me
and now I think I'm more of the security
professional that says here's some
problems that I'm trying to solve can
you help me with it
and I think so yes we're looking at the
solution but I think as we look at the
partners we're kind of looking for their
expertise in the space especially what
is their expertise with Google cloud is
it something that they support kind of
ancillary maybe they mostly support AWS
and they have a me-too approach to
Google cloud or are they truly a Google
partner and they've really thought
through their approach of implementing
their solution in Google cloud but to me
it's it's twofold value it's ideally we
yes we want a good solution but we
really want a good partner who can kind
of understand our context who can kind
of grow with us and we can kind of
leverage a lot of the expertise that
they built up over the years
so for from me specifically it was it
was feature parity and and I don't
necessarily mean feature parity from the
perspective of like hey we're looking
for exactly what we run on Prem but also
looking at potentially deficiencies that
you have you know if you have this
exercise where you can actually build
something from scratch and build
something new then what you're looking
for is potentially looking for maybe
there's something you didn't look at or
maybe there is a new feature that is now
available that your partner might be
dealing with and so then you go through
that
versus by mentality well of course we
could all probably build it and spend
the cycles actually doing that but it's
something if somebody's out there doing
it better and doing it well and has a
bit of maturity and longevity in the
service they've built then you've kind
of been able to instill a bit of
confidence in that vendor and be able to
realize that you know you can partner
with them and see how you can work
together to to kind of you know you know
build a service build this product so
what I'd say is don't be afraid of
finding things that might be not running
properly or not might not be working
properly but if anything you might be
able to find that in the partner that
you they partner up with and they're
just double-clicking on the torch that
you mentioned about using cloud armor
how to think about application security
fee could you share your thoughts you
have done a lot of groundbreaking work
there yes so should companies think
about application security generally
yeah so you know we deal with a lot of
bots and BOTS both being good and both
and both being bad and so we were
looking at ways of being able to have
you know this this portability aspect of
being able to deploy something no matter
where at the same time also
understanding that you know potentially
there were some things that might we
might not have been catching so being
able to get a take advantage of a lot of
the behavioral aspects of traffic that
you know a lot of companies are kind of
looking into the space and then
partnering up with replays and seeing
how they've been able to kind of excel
at a lot of the visibility that we we
might not have been able to see is
something that that we found pretty
intriguing and led us to kind of go
through this test scenario perfect thank
you just to follow up with the comments
from my panelists there are there are
when you look at especially hybrid
environments where you you're going from
traditionally on premise environments
and trying to secure workloads in the
cloud space most of most of the time we
tend to approach them with a mentality
of what we knew about in the on-premise
space however because the infrastructure
and the visibility doesn't always exist
in the same way in the cloud space you
have to
be very focused on at least working with
vendor products that provide you some
sense of visibility for the different
workloads that you have if you're
primarily say compute engine heavy then
you want to look at products that give
you visibility from both the network
layers and then from the compute engine
and how the cloud as a space and all the
services are running in it are
interconnected because that's the only
way you have a really good way of trying
to make sure that your policies your
baseline policies from a cad perspective
from a DLP perspective from
vulnerability management perspective are
covered by the tool sets that you decide
to put in place we work with different
vendor products some of them were
actually listed on the slide previously
quality is one of them plus a couple
others we are also looking at the
[Music]
ability to have visibility across the
cloud space to see all of the services
connectivity and how that is laid out
then create and come up with strategies
around securing all of that in the cloud
once base mark yes I think I just one
comment back that kind of listening to
all the responses is that it if you're
migrating to the cloud you might not
have an app that that's perfect or you
might have a world might not have a
workflow that's that's really secure
really clean you've kind of think about
what how the risk and the threats are
changing from moving from an on-premise
environment into the cloud and this also
gives you the unique opportunity to look
at what's working what's not working if
you're using a partner solution right
now that maybe isn't going to migrate to
the cloud that well you have the
opportunity to say well maybe this isn't
going to work out for me and I need to
change that and that's one of the the
I'd say the journey is that we had a
Loblaws we had a few partners that maybe
just didn't work out so well in the
cloud and we had to say well we have to
pivot we have to make sure
we're gonna be one percent successful
and having that loyalty to one specific
partner maybe isn't the right thing to
do there are a few you know people in
the audience who are working for a
security vendors what are you expecting
your security vendors to do you know in
order for these companies to be
successful with you and have a true
partnership with you that's a really
tough question and so specifically about
being like cloud native and really
having that uh like taking a number of
steps back and saying well we have to do
things differently in the cloud it's not
about traditional infrastructure anymore
so what's what's different the cloud how
we make sure that what we're building is
going to be is going to take into the
principles that were looking to do the
philosophy of cloud and DevOps and how
are we building it for that I think this
is a great question anybody in the
audience wants to chime in that what
would be the right security partner as
folks are evaluating different companies
they want to partner with for security
what are the key things that do you
think are important in addition to what
Mark said right if you're thinking about
a partner what would be the right
characteristics of that partner so a lot
of that at least from my or my
perspective is just the portability so
whether it's something that you can run
on prime as well as running an in cloud
and make it that very seamless if
anything I think that's where you know
some vendors might not have focused on
one areas opposed to the other but it's
that portability factor that makes it
easy to be able to transition you know
we got really good at being able to
migrate workloads but we you know if
we're not able to migrated appliance or
migrate a product and then we
essentially kind of pigeon-holed
ourselves into backhauling traffic back
to a data center in order to be able to
have that same little protection and I
think yeah so kind of to echo on that I
think we look for partners who can help
us in multi cloud environments I think
our our desire and an intent is
everything in GCP but our reality is
always going to be there's going to be
some laggard application that's built
specifically to AWS it's going to take
us a long time to get out of so we do
need consistent coverage across multiple
cloud environments and I think the other
thing is is that today when we look at
any solution I we just won't take any
solution unless it has a restful api
interface
because if that vendor cannot let us
integrate and orchestrate with other
solutions yeah we are not even
interested in looking at that solution
at that point perfect thank you any
other comments on this what he just
stated
especially when you have multi cloud
environments you want to have that
integration especially at the API level
so that your provision of say the
reporting or even integration with
existing script tool sets you know be
they on-premise or be they in the cloud
space is seamless and appears the same
because when you have people go into
different tools you know then you end up
with the same traditional risks that we
have in on-premise environments you know
multiple tool sets different data sets
and not perfect so I think other thing
that'll be I think useful for the
audience will be to understand what were
the key lessons learned as you went on
your journey to Google Cloud or any
other public cloud in general and I was
thinking more in terms of not just the
technical lessons learned but
organizationally how security should be
done in the cloud where this how
organizations should be set up how the
role should be defined there any key
nuggets that you guys want to share that
in that will be useful for the audience
Marc if you could start video I think
what really helped helped us sell when
we started our journey was having a team
that we dedicated to to cloud migration
and adopting cloud principles like
forget about tack and forget about
partners and and the workloads the first
thing you need to consider when you want
to adopt the cloud is philosophy and
what you are like really adopting those
principles adopting DevOps principles
and making sure everybody is on the same
page with what you're looking to achieve
what's going to the cloud what are the
actual benefits that your organization's
going to be getting from the cloud and
how you how are you going to implement
those so having that core team that
really were the bleeding edge of
understanding what those principles were
was very advantageous for making it
successful right off the bat and what
Mark said you know I think that you know
my learning is that you know sure cloud
a lot of
are easier in cloud but there are no
shortcuts like you know you you know you
have to have processes you have to have
planning in place and and that is my you
know my key takeaway from from cloud
migration and in my first advice to
people who are kind of starting their
journey yeah so when I first wrote my
first cloud security reference model I
totally had it wrong so I basically had
the statement that said I want to make
cloud just as secure as on-prem and and
the the fallacy was in that statement
was that I was I was aiming for parity
when really if we think about it we go
to cloud not to co-locate but we go to
cloud to transform we transform our
applications we move to infrastructure
as code blue-green environments we have
to do the same thing from a security
perspective and we really have to
transform what we're doing but more
importantly I think that we we can never
set our goals too high from a cloud
security perspective we always have to
define what is my best-case scenario and
and even if you have to temporarily take
a take reality and put it to the side to
say I want an environment that is always
doing compliance auditing 24 by 7 in
real time
I want scans to be happening as things
are spun up we have to hold those as the
ideals and I think that just as we're
seeing cloud transform and security
transform I think what you're hearing
here is that I think as security
professionals we're also transforming
our approach and we are moving more
towards automation more towards bot
driven triggers because we know that in
these cloud environments they're so
ephemeral and they move so fast that's
the only real way we're going to keep up
some my takeaway is don't be afraid to
break things you know you know and you
know what come out at first start with
what Mark alluded to was like don't be
afraid to break culture you know a lot
of times it's a mentality of that you
know you can only do things a certain
way and you know by breaking that you
can actually technically do things a
little bit better but don't be afraid to
actually break your environments you
know we were in a fortunate situation
where you know we reach out to our
customer engineer and said hey we want a
DDoS Google and you know probably within
three seconds he said yeah let's do it
let's be great you know he was really
really
sited and you know when you realize that
you have partners that want to see you
break things you want to see these kind
of failures because that's the only we
learn you know these environments as
ephemeral as they are they're great
learning experience especially if you
are first you know migrating to you know
it's a public cloud for the first time
but the same time - you're also going to
find deficiencies possibly in your in
your automation process or in your build
process you will find failures that
you'll learn from and you will learn how
to you know make your environments you
know more resilient and better in our
environment one of the issues that we
run into is orchestration because we
have different business units and some
of them have you know even though we're
the same company we have different
approaches - based on what the business
value the team is adding and how they
approach so there has to be in the cloud
space there has to be some kind of
strategy created even for diversity of
different business teams so that you end
up with the same mindset in terms of how
you approach moving in workloads into
the cloud space and also securing them
orchestration has been a big deal like
Jason just stated having those two sets
that allow you to automate would
actually enhance your migration in a
very secure way and also be able to
monitor what's happening from a security
perspective in that cloud space perfect
so I think in the last question I wanted
to cover was more kind of forward
thinking so clouds are evolving very
quickly security paradigms are evolving
quickly as kind of security experts in
the field where do you see this headed
in six months or 12 months and with the
goal of folks who are building their
solution now how can the future proof or
they're building so any thoughts you
guys want to share on that you know
containers or you know service measures
or anything that you guys think is where
we are headed and what impact it would
have on security and how that should be
baked into the design that's being built
so you know just from you know being
from some partner sessions and some
council sessions I it's it's funny how
we are you know how we're changing the
way we monitor things and how we do you
know previously we would log something
it would actually go somewhere and then
we would be analyzing it you know post
event yeah now we're getting more into
like streamlined processing you know or
inline processing we're actually able to
you know leverage things like cloud
functions you know over a door slam
those or whatever in order to be able to
do processing in line so we actually
gather more intelligence before you know
before the event gets logged so we're
actually our response times are gonna
eventually become a lot quicker and I
think what we're gonna do is we're gonna
get away from the traditional aspects of
having these huge dashboards where we're
constantly looking for something to
happen and more or less become more more
aware of what actually happened and
gather more intelligence from that
perfect anybody else from the panel I I
can take this one too so I think that
you know the cloud enables all of us to
move faster and that includes you know
both the heavy users and or some
panelists here and as well as the vendor
to evolve stairs to evolve their
solutions over time so that's kind of
you know the next six months are going
to be always exciting that's because
everybody can move faster so I'm you
know really looking forward to see what
what you know the vendor is introduced
into this space and kind of you know
what kind of new ideas they bring in the
market so I think the one thing I'll add
those are both great points is security
right now is even with moving to the
cloud it's still there's still certain
gates that you look at you're going to
code test and you're going to do a QA
process with cloud and and and doing
development in the cloud moving so fast
now it can't be about gates any more
security solutions have to just have to
be aligned and running along with with
development and and workload development
and tearing up and tearing or putting up
and tearing down workloads so we've
stuff to make sure that as we build our
security solutions and as we build our
platforms that we make sure that
Security's Security's aligned and moving
alongside with development
perfect edition yeah so architectural II
from a security architecture perspective
I always I always like to think about
things in in layers and you know the the
solutions is never the security program
right our security program is never a
bucket of vendor solutions that we buy
it's really about what our strategy is
but then architectural e at the very
bottom of that strategy are going to be
core things about how we do security
incident management and you know whether
you in in house your sock or whether you
outsource it we outsource ours to secure
works because that gives us the human
analog and the runbook processes because
every solution that we buy is going to
generate an event and then we always
have to say what are you going to do
with it right so it's great to buy a lot
of things generated events but if you
don't have the work force to actually
deal with it that's a problem so at the
very core foundation we focused on
security incident response with secure
works we focused on security
orchestration with ServiceNow and then
event collection with Splunk and then
every solution that we we built kind of
interplays with all three of those at
the bottom tier so it's really about you
know what it what is the foundation
architecture that you're going to build
that will eventually support all the
security controls that you're going to
use
[Music]